faltan 90 segundos para la medianoche en
el reloj del fin del mundo Y eso
significa que la humanidad está más
cerca que nunca de un cataclismo global
es lo que el boletín de los científicos
atómicos un grupo de expertos encargado
de este proyecto y que incluye a 10
premios Nobel anunció Este martes el
reloj simbólico es ajustado cada año
desde 1947 para dar cuenta de los
riesgos globales de una catástrofe la
medianoche es la hora fatídica que se
espera que nunca se alcance la guerra en
Ucrania y la amenaza nuclear llevo los
científicos a adelantar el reloj de 10
segundos En comparación con el año
pasado
no se puede descartar la posibilidad del
uso nuclear los accidentes los errores y
los errores de cálculo podrían provocar
una escalada no intencionada y Putin
podría escalar deliberadamente si se
enfrentara a la perspectiva de la
derrota Si las fuerzas rusas fueran
expulsadas del territorio ucraniano
Putin no ha dado indicios de estar
dispuesto a aceptar la derrota además de
la guerra en Ucrania los científicos
tuvieron en cuenta la crisis climática
la pandemia del covid-19 pero también la
desinformación entre otros sin embargo
los expertos no pierden Esperanza
creo que entonces existe la posibilidad
de que pulsemos un botón de reinicio y
reabramos una serie de iniciativas
diplomáticas para abordar los retos de
las armas nucleares el cambio climático
y las demás amenazas a las que nos
enfrentamos hoy en día
el reloj fue creado durante la Guerra
Fría para advertir de los riesgos
nucleares que podrían llevar a una
destrucción global lo más lejos al fin
del mundo crítico fue en 1991 al final
de esta guerra estaba entonces a 17
minutos de la medianoche